the Joe Rogan experience on the way to
get coke they're gonna test you it's not
in your body but you were totally on the
influence of cocaine you know I mean I
mean that's like I'm I just have opened
up a whole new can of worms I don't want
I don't want my brothers together but
I'm saying like am i under there it's
not in me but it's not influenced by
completely yeah and it is it's like it's
like a kid on Christmas morning if
you're a drug addict you anticipate that
see I equated it with fun the gambling
you know yeah cuz what's gambling it's
just instant fun yeah you're bored to
death now you're still watching sports
yeah I don't like it as much
no of course not I used to bet again I
like pure gambling people who people who
bet on stuff and handicap it that's like
a job who wants a job I don't a job I
don't the research [ __ ] game I just
wanna bet find out who's injured yeah
yeah that's not action right cuz if you
kind of know what might happen right I
used to I used to go to the Mirage
sportsbook in Vegas they have a line on
everything you could bet on two kids
playing wiffle ball in Minnesota at the
Mirage they have a line on everything
it's a it's just the it's heaven for
gamblers so I would bet on sports I knew
nothing about it then do cocaine and
like 4:00 o'clock in the morning I'm
going around people at the bar going hey
did you see the high school lacrosse
scores
I got Ramapo versus Dom Bosco Prep I
would bet on the cross look cuz I knew
nothing about it
Wow I would put each Super Bowl from
2004 to 11 I had 10 grand on the coin to
us mmm pangram that according to us and
seven at a times I probably I by five
times I probably lost so before to
kick-off I was down ten gram now how far
behind are you if you all lifetime if
you want to look at lifetime gambling
how far just gambling yeah yeah cuz
everybody's behind like I don't know
anyway two million why probably three
point to play though is what I've lost
gambling holy [ __ ]
if I had to be I do that math in my head
a couple of you know yeah I I'd say I'm
not about that's over specific three
point two is very specific yeah because
I know I updated in my own
because I'm obsessed about that don't
you talk about you know to lose that
much money got a bit of a Jets a lot I I
had an uncle I had an uncle I do this
joke oh man my uncle was a degenerate
gambler and he said you know art when I
was a kid I was into the Jets and then I
got into girls and then I got back into
the Jets cuz I realized there's times
when a girl won't [ __ ] you but the Jets
will always [ __ ]
[Applause]